okay we have nearly 7,000 viewers and
listeners who now are subscribers to the
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t you can
discuss politics and news and current
events and philosophy and culture really
whatever you want with other viewers and
listeners respectfully we don't allow
over trolling on the subreddit few
notable discussions that i spotted this
morning starting with one about
YouTube's
new plan for promoting and funding
authoritative news
so the idea as I understand it there's a
wired article that was linked to is that
YouTube is going to handpick channels
that they believe provide as the name
says authoritative news and to give them
funding to expand and of course this is
simultaneously very exciting if you're
going to be one of the channels chosen
but also very concerning to some because
of the idea that there is going to be
some central clearinghouse on such a
major platform like YouTube which will
decide what are the news outlets that
can be trusted in some way now I am
trying to get us into this of course I'm
talking to our YouTube happen and I told
her buried directly we want to be a part
of this I don't know how these channels
are going to be selected as far as we've
been told Pat no decision has been made
yet exactly but my interest was going to
be passed along the right channel so
hopefully you know it's one of these
things were unconcerned about it but I
also will if YouTube is doing it we want
to be a part of it for sure yeah we got
to stay consistent on this right like if
we're selected it's a great thing but if
we're not selected it's an abomination
it's like jobs numbers it's jobs numbers
before Trump was president you couldn't
trust jobs numbers and now that he is
and the jobs numbers are pretty good or
good enough they're really reliable
numbers it's the same thing this is
absolutely atrocious of for YouTube to
do unless we're included in which case
fantastic initiative also from the David
Pakman show subreddit do we really want
Bret Cavanaugh's confirmation to be an
election issue the argument made here by
this user on the subreddit is that it
may actually be a backfire for Democrats
to try to make the confirmation an
election issue and generally speaking
the idea
is that if you consider that in 2016
given the exact same situation it didn't
work out particularly well for Democrats
that maybe it wouldn't work out that
well to oppose in any way possible the
Cavanaugh confirmation this time either
I kind of disagree because the Democrats
actually failed to really carry it out
to its full conclusion and you were they
could to push through if it would have
been possible the Merrick garland
confirmation hearing so I just disagree
in the polling of our own audience of
leftists suggested it would be great for
Democrats to oppose the confirmation I
guess one argument would be that it's
futile right because it looks like
Cavanaugh is gonna get through either
way yes and then you're wetting your
gunpowder you know you got to save some
of that political capital for other
issues and let this one be the problem
with that is that if you can actually
take over the House and Senate in
November and successfully delay the
confirmation hearings long enough you
actually might be able to prevent the
confirmation from happening
I don't know I don't know the answer I
could be convinced either way also from
the david pakman show subreddit we did
on the bonus show a story about
starbucks eliminating plastic straws and
we generally said it's a good thing but
it's mostly for PR for starbucks and
there have been a number of articles
that i've been pointed that have been
pointed out to me including one which
explains that actually plastic straws
the kind that starbucks is getting rid
of are really important for people with
certain disabilities who have trouble
drinking otherwise and i genuinely did
not know too much about this and i guess
i continue not to know enough about it
to know whether the replacement proposal
from starbucks presents a problem for
people who for health reasons need to
drink from from plastic straws but i
admit this is not an issue i knew very
much about yeah probably so they're
going to do that adult sippy cup thing
yeah so you know I imagine some people
with disabilities won't be able to use
that they'll need the straw yeah I don't
wonder what Starbucks will do maybe keep
some in the back available upon request
here's a serious question is not
providing plastic straws arguably a
violation of the Americans with
Disabilities Act if it's so crucial a
thing to people who need a plastic straw
to drink I don't know the answer I'm
genuinely asking these questions and I
do plan to look into more about this and
lastly disgusting David's dirty carbon
foot
this is the second or third sub reddit
thread where people are alleging that we
are not an environmentally friendly show
because we have lights in the studio we
have televisions in the studio which
consume power because I sometimes fly on
airplanes and you know what I have to
say this is obvious trolling and I don't
even think we should engage with it like
it could someone Siri you think that
these are serious criticisms that our
program is actually counter to the
pro-environmental narrative because we
own lecture listen I could sit in a
completely dark room we could really
reduce the energy consumption of the
show is that a show anybody would watch
we would save power yeah we could just
not have a show at all for that matter I
wonder if this person is you know
totally environmentally friendly doesn't
drive doesn't eat meat any of that stuff
because otherwise they're throwing
stones from a glass house it sounds like
even if you only lentils which have a
relatively low carbon impact it's still
not zero right so like what what are we
talking about here and this just seems
like someone who has a lot of free time
I think is what I would say join the
discussion at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT today's episode is made possible
in part by better help calm slash Pakman
I've spoken about the unfair and
unfortunate stigma that there can be
around therapy there shouldn't be and
better help makes things even easier for
you if you've been thinking about
getting involved and working with a
therapist you get access to fully
licensed experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer all you have to do is go to
better help calm slash Pakman you fill
out a questionnaire they match you with
a counselor that'll work best for you
you can ask if you want that your
therapist not be religious if that is
important to you and at any point if you
think your therapist is not a good fit
you can switch and work with somebody
else it's less expensive than seeing a
counselor in person but better help also
gives you unlimited access to your
counselor you can talk to them every day
if you want you will not get that with
an in-person therapist so go to better
help calm slash Pakman so easy to sign
up and get started we've put a link in
the video description if your watch
on YouTube check it out better help calm
/pa que ma n